27 year old left-hander cole irvine he's
10 and 13 at 3-9-4
e-r-a urban's last outing a victory on
the road against the angels
and that'll bring up kyle seeger
here's the one-two on the way and that
swung out a mess in a breaking ball away
seeger k's france left it first the
mariners failed to score with the a's
coming up in the bottom half chris
flecks in the pride of memorial high
school and
from a nearby newark he's 12 and six a
three six six cra one and two against
the a's this year chris flexon now
taking a look at center fielder starling
martay
marty a big night last night two for
three with a home run and a double the
2-2
swaying and a miss good fastball to 95
first punch-out tonight for chris
flexton olsen one for three last night
he got a hanging breaking ball three two
for marco gonzalez hit a way out to
right field
flex and ready looks in as a sign from
murph
now the wind up and the one-two on the
way big curveball strike three called he
got him looking uncle charlie showing up
on the doorstop right there on the
outside corner back-to-back strikeouts
for chris flexon what a pitch to freeze
matt olson and that's it for the a's in
the bottom of the first we go to the top
of the second marin is nothing the a's
nothing and tom murphy is four for five
lifetime against irvin runners lee from
first and second is swung out and missed
down he goes off speed
murphy k's second strikeout for cole
urban that'll bring up dylan moore who's
batting at 183 and
12 home runs 43 rbis
now the 01 delivery and that's swung on
bounced a second one step two is right
up with the harrison throws to first in
time and urban works out of it the
mariners leave two runners on
and they go down in the second and after
one and a half the is in the mariners
nothing nothing jed lowry banning 246.
flexon has had a great change up this
year here is the lineup and the one two
again swing and a miss fastball on the
outside corner for strike three that is
three consecutive strikeouts for flexon
getting martay and olson in the first
and he strikes out jen lowery leading
off the bottom of the second one away
for the eight
two gone and mitch haniger stands in 3-2
again
and a breaking ball strike three caught
henniger his hat at the top of the zone
and a one two three third for cole urban
picks up his third strikeout of the
night
on the bottom of the third no score
catcher sean murphy leads things off in
the bottom of the third
two and two sean murphy
home third no score pets fastball right
down the pipe he took it turned away and
he knew it right
seeker leading things off in the
mariners fourth inning
seeger with a deep drive out to right
center this is gone
home run kyle seeger
with one swing of the bat he becomes
only the ninth mariner in franchise
history
with a 35 homer 100 rbi season
another fantastic milestone for one of
the all-time great seattle mariners kyle
seeger one-on-one on and now jared
kelneck will stand in one two breaking
ball strike three called kelnick has
gone to looking
good slider that time from cole picks up
his fourth k of the night and that'll
bring up catcher tom murphy
art hit blistered into center field here
comes toro
martay's throw home
not in time toro scores standing and the
mariners get their second run this
inning it comes with two outs off the
bat at tom murphy two nothing mariners
in the fourth and here's right fielder
mark canna two-nothing mariners lead
and again the one two from flex and on
the way to mark canna swing and i'm
missing a fastball for strike three
that's going to retire the side and that
is strikeout number five for chris
flexon who has the a shut out through
four we go to the top of the fifth
inning here in oakland it's the mariners
too and the athletics
crawford is though for two tonight and
he's popped out and lied out
4149 tonight here's a drive blooping its
way into left and tony kemp coming on
goes into a slide and makes a good catch
so crawford making a bid and kemp coming
in and sliding on the turf
and he robs him and that's out number
one in the fifth two nothing mariners
lead here is first baseman ty france
here's the pitch the france swinging a
high fly ball deep to left field going
back as kemp to the wanting track
looking up and goodbye baseball
tai france with a home run to left field
his 17th home run of the season and it
gives the mariners a three nothing lead
here in the top of any number five
it's drawn the infield in and here's
luis terence
who is one for two and four for six this
year against irvin
and terrence at the plate he's a
right-handed hitter and it's swung on
her missed off speed down and away so
terrence strikes out
two out fifth strikeout for irvin
and that'll bring up abraham toro and
here's the pitch by irvin swing on and
blue foul first base side long run for
olson still racing still racing and he
gets there he makes a running catch
engineers the photographer as well just
to the right
of the mariners dugout so good running
catch by olson takes advantage of the
foul territory here so the mariners get
one they leave two
and halfway through our ball game today
after four and a half it's three nothing
seattle chapman leads off for the acer
ball game goes to the bottom of the
fifth free nothing seattle
3-2 pitch on the way to chapman and matt
hits a deep drive into center kellnick
going back way back at the track to the
wall he will watch it
fly and the eggs are on the board a
center field shot by chapman
and here on the bottom of the fifth it's
three to one seattle
so one on two outs one in three one
mariners and here is second baseman josh
harrison the stretch and the pitch
swinging a line shot to short right
there jp crawford to make the catch and
that will retire the side there's dylan
moore right-handed hitter kira takes his
time and comes to the plate high
fastball kelnick took off and he's got a
stolen base that looks like a foul ball
i was just going to say you can very
clearly see the foul ball
and bow mel is incensed now
and he is nose to nose with greg gibson
and now bull mill is gone
and the delivery and is swung on and
missed and down goes dylan moore there's
crawford a left-handed hitter
the pause at the belt on the way and
it's swinging on a ground ball to first
olson he's got it he's gonna go to the
bag for the and all of that and the ace
came out of it fine
although it took some twists and turns
to get there and the a's skipper of
being ejected
runner left in second we go to the
bottom of the sixth and the mariners
lead the a's three to one
matt olson struck out looking in a pop
out to seeger here comes a 3-2 flexon
working here in the six 3-2 to olson
fastball swung on and miss struck him
out
two down brings up the veteran's switch
hitter jed lowry just one two to lowry
the pitch breaking ball swung on a miss
struck him out seven k's for flex and he
goes one two three into six to the
seventh we go infield at double play
depth luis terrence the hitter
flicked into left center with some carry
to it
france is at third base plenty deep to
bring home ty france it's a sac fly off
the bat of luis terrence
that makes it 4-1 mariners cannonbase
hit the rightness strikeout tonight 4-1
mariners into the wind and the pitch
fastball swung on a miss struck him out
three consecutive strikeouts now
for chris flexing he's got eight on the
night one away here in the seventh
kelnick has walked and struck out and
walked the right-hander throws it swung
on a fly ball left field kept coming on
chapman going out and it's gonna be kept
losing his cap and he makes the catch ty
france has emerged as a really tough
hitter
two on two out top of the eighth he is
down 4-1 the pitcher ground ball to
short right there elvis flips the second
in time for the force and we go to the
bottom of the eighth
and it's the mariners four and the
athletics one what a ball game tonight
here in oakland mariners lead four to
one late bottom of the eighth inning two
down here's harrison old for three on
the night here's the wind-up and the 3-2
swinging a fly ball into shallow left
center field kelnick racing in racing
dives and he makes the catch
holy smokes what a superman catch by the
kid jared kellnick shallow left center
field off with a crack of the bat flying
in with the greatest of ease and he robs
josh harrison of a basement and there's
your final out in the bottom of the
eighth inning on a spectacular catch by
jared kellnick
and that'll bring up right fielder mark
canna
going after the first pitch straight
away centerfield koelnik puts it away
the mariners have taken the first three
games in oakland they have secured a
series win
and the seattle mariners now a season
best 14 games over 500.